[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan winhorst ESPN senior NBA writer
kind enough to join us we have All-Star
Weekend festivities
let me ask you about a couple of things
here the uh Russell Westbrook situation
of who wants him or does anybody want
him and uh the contract status that he
would bring with him
well clearly we have a number of players
who have already executed buyouts and
already playing with their new teams so
if somebody wanted him he'd be on a
roster now I would just say that it's
February whatever it's mid-February we
have a long time between now and when uh
the deadline would be to be added to a
roster so he has time there could be an
injury somewhere else but
um you know typically in a buyout
situation you're looking for a guy to
plug a role to fill a limited role in
most cases and that's not been the mo
that Westbrook has portrayed I I do
think he'll play in the NBA again
but it's just not that simple so um I
don't exactly know why the Jazz haven't
bought him out I suspect it's because he
doesn't want to sit out there on the
market without a job but it's really a
simple negotiation they'll reduce his
salary by what he could sign for
and he moves on with his life it's it's
not it's not it's not the Jazz choice at
this point I believe it's Russell's what
about Kevin Love's situation
this one is a little bit more
complicated especially for a guy who's
been in a place almost a decade won a
title there
um
you don't see guys like this get bought
out number one guys who are still you
know players who can contribute to a
playoff team you just don't see it
secondly
the Cavs let them go and this let him go
wherever he wants like Miami is one of
the teams that could could get him Dan
and Miami has actually had a lot of
success against Cleveland this year and
that could be a first round of uh series
the last thing you want if you're the
Cavs is to have Kevin Love you're paying
them 30 million by the way this year he
comes in and hits two three-pointers in
game four against you it's not a good
look so there might be some negotiation
on where he goes there but it's an
interesting situation because this is a
guy who has a long history with that
organization has gone through thick and
thin has been on the trade block a dozen
times and they've kept him and now it's
going to end quietly because basically
the Cavs don't need them right now
they've um they haven't played them for
the last 12 games and they've looked
really good during it and so I think he
went to the team and was like
is there any chance you're going to play
me anytime soon like well
no but maybe there'll be an injury or
something and he he wanted out so it was
some situation to monitor but I'm still
kind of surprised that after all this
that Kevin Love is going to end his time
with the Cavs probably a guy who
deserves his number retired there but to
be honest with you in a sort of middle
of the night buyout during All-Star
break what about the Lakers reuniting
with LeBron could you see Kevin fit into
whatever they're doing
I think the Lakers are definitely
kicking the tires there and looking uh I
don't think it's the best fit for him I
think uh I certainly in Miami would be a
good fit because they need size and
shooting I don't know if the Cavs are
going to allow that as part of the
buyout that's part of what I think is
under discussion the team that I think
is more it might be more interesting is
Phoenix
um because James Jones uh was Kevin's
teammate they have a good relationship
they have an open roster spot but I
watched the Suns play last night they
played against the Clippers and Monty
Williams played like 11 or 12 players
and after the game said I can't even
play this many and that's before Kevin
Durant comes back so I wonder if there's
even room I mean there's room on the
roster but there's room to play him so
um he may take a little bit of time
um but the LeBron thing is interesting
you know it's kind of funny Dan
LeBron played and played with a few
weeks I don't know was over a month ago
and before the game
he was all hugs with Kevin Uh Kevin got
married last summer LeBron was at his
wedding there's great Affinity there
even though they had a you know up and
down time as teammates and it was just
like they were best of friends and then
the game started and LeBron relentlessly
attacked him on the court just just just
went for his throat on defense yeah and
the cast had to pull him out of the game
and that is actually kind of the reason
why
they just had to stop playing him
because he's not shooting well enough
anymore to justify him his defense and
so like I'm sure LeBron wants them at
the same time LeBron knows what Kevin
Love is at this point in his career
you've covered LeBron since he was in
high school and here he is the all-time
leading scorer it's rare when somebody
uh moves past all of the hype around
them and I don't know of another athlete
who had more hype going in to being a
professional than LeBron did how would
you
capsulize this of LeBron from high
school to LeBron the all-time leading
scorer
well being there last week was it last
week it feels long ago being there last
week I had I'll take two things away
from that night one
um he brought everybody from his life
into that game
um I know enough to never predict I know
enough to be able to say I don't know
what's going to happen in the NBA having
said that I would have gambled on the
broad naked in the 36 points that night
because everybody was there and so to
see all of those people from his really
before he was even a teenager you know
he had the family uh Frankie and Pam
Walker who took him in when he was fifth
grade LeBron missed 100 days of school
as a fourth grader fifth grade had
perfect attendance completely changed
his life the discipline the punctuality
you want to piss LeBron off be late to
something all that came from that family
and they were there just as important it
was to have his mother there so it's as
important as it was to have his family
there so that seeing all those people
there for the total Circle Journey from
when he started to to then because even
going back to his first game as a pro he
was petrified and kind of alone it was
out in Sacramento it was sort of a weird
feeling he wasn't he didn't feel great
with that team that wasn't the memory
the memory was more even before that the
second thing is
in the post-game locker room with him
and his his two sons particularly uh
brani I mean I remember when brawny
would come into he didn't come in a lot
but he would come in the locker rooms
when LeBron was in Cleveland and he
would go around to the The Ice buckets
where guys used to uh you know they
still do you know ice their feet and he
would pick the ice up and start throwing
it across the room and LeBron would be
over there putting on his suit back when
guys wore suits and he'd be tightening
his tie and he'd scream over at brawny
brawny you know he would like you know
you know scold them and now here they
are uh you know he's really probably two
years away from making the NBA is having
a Spectacular Senior season uh six
months ago I wouldn't have said I
thought he was for sure going to be an
NBA player I now feel like he will be
okay and so that Circle
again of just is a reminder of how long
this journey has been is that he used to
scold this kid to not play around and
now he practically put on a uniform and
fit in that locker room
we're talking to Brian windhorst of the
mothership senior NBA writer I'm still
trying to figure out this Anthony Davis
situation with the Lakers because it it
feels uneven like there's something
there and go back to the night that he
broke the scoring record where I think
Anthony Davis was sitting down and said
hey we were losing and I was frustrated
and my thought is well you've been
losing all season long so that wasn't
something new to you in that moment so
what am what am I missing with Anthony
Davis here
I don't that explanation was hard to
accept in that moment
um I don't care if you were Owen Owen 40
that's a celebration of 20 years of your
teammate and even if you were annoyed
about something even if you were annoyed
at LeBron you certainly wouldn't back
that way so that was a very strange
thing I can't explain that
um I do think that you know Patrick
Beverly came out after he was traded and
then released and indicated that there
was something else besides the
basketball that was causing problems
with the Lakers my response to that was
what was also the basketball because
they are they are very poorly uh you
know put together team before the trades
um but it does lead you to wonder what's
going on there I wish I could say oh
yeah Dan I know exactly what it is and
it's these three things
um I do think that there's something
amiss there but I also think that NBA
seasons are very long and very
restorative and so they've got 22 23
games left I know they're in 13th Place
it's actually kind of laughable that we
spend as much time as we do talking
about team in 13th Place but at the same
time I also can't look at you and say
it's impossible that they couldn't
squeeze in to the main playoffs I think
they'll probably end up in the play-in
um and so while I admit that there might
be something amiss there I don't think
Anthony Davis
wants to not be a Laker I my
understanding is he's still 100 bought
into that and whatever issues there are
there is still time to salvage something
out of this season and so I think those
are two things to keep in mind as we try
to figure that out yo Ryan do you uh
answer your own questions it's the
Lakers just like we covered the Cowboys
like your network loves the cow how can
we get the Cowboys into every single
show how do we get the I I've been there
in those rundown meetings where they go
uh hey can we can we work this into the
show and almost ever on a daily basis
there so that's always going to be the
fascination wherever LeBron goes he's
going to be in the in the mix and the
Cowboys are always going to be in the
mix
yeah just know that I fight the good
fight in production meetings and I and I
bring up you know hey you know the
Timberwolves have been playing pretty
good recently I go yeah about the yeah
well I can't finish LeBron done against
the Timberwolves let's look at his stats
against the Timberwolves what I'm always
amazed by is that like we do we like do
Lakers coverage at you know seven and
eight in the morning Eastern I'm like
that all their fans are still asleep
Uh Kevin Durant now with another team
he's 34. I'm just wondering if how is
history going to treat Kevin Durant it's
all said and done
yeah I mean you'd actually be a really
good person to say that because your
perspective over the Long Haul uh your
voice you know contributes to that
um I am somebody who has Inc incredible
admiration for Durant's uh abilities and
and the way he's recovered from injuries
and I will always appreciate what Durant
did at the 2020 Olympics we're actually
here and played in 2021 he's coming off
an Achilles injury really probably
should not have been I should not have
been playing went over to Tokyo and I'm
telling you I don't know how many people
remember those Olympics because you know
it was a weird part of the schedule the
NBA season was like had just ended and
they were doing the draft and free
agency like while they were playing
Durant saved USA's backside he I mean
Popovich did some moves
um you know Drew holiday and Devin
Booker flew over right from the finals
but they were going to lose a couple of
those games and Durant just absolutely
carried the US to the gold medal
um it is as much of an accomplishment as
has happened in in uh you with Team USA
basketball in the history of the program
I don't think he just gets a proper
credit for it and I also am a very big
believer that the Warriors don't win
those two those two finals without him
the 2017 Cavs team the first one that
they won they won that series 4-1 that
2017 Cavs team was loaded they were
awesome that was when Kyrie and LeBron
were at their Peak playing together the
Cavs had made some additions to that
team and um got some three-point
shooting they went 12-1 through the east
playoffs now I will not defend that the
East was exactly that deep that year but
that team was awesome they don't beat
that team without Durant and the concept
to me that Durant was a you know a a a
you know riding in the back of the bus
to use Charles Barkley's with all due
respect I just don't think that's true I
think I think Durant was sitting uh
shotgun with uh Steph Curry and he won
they won the next year the next year the
Kyrie had been traded and that wasn't
the same but then in 2019
the Warriors lost because Durant got
hurt you know like I think that case is
better if they go up against you know
Supreme Kawhi letter in 2019 and then
they you know they roll over the Raptors
4-1 but excuse me my good friends they
lost Durant and they and they fell apart
they couldn't win so like to me I don't
think his legacy needs an Iota but I
know that he feels that pressure and and
frankly people keep calling about how
it's uh it's a it's a tragedy a
basketball tragedy I got to qualify the
basketball tragedy that those Nets never
played together well it's a tragedy that
Kevin Durant lost you know three years
of his career and chances other titles
messing around with a guy who wasn't
serious about it you know Kyrie undercut
that team and then the hardened thing
Harden Bears some responsibility
um but he those are three prime years
that he could have stayed in Golden
State and won some more and now here he
is in his mid-30s sort of thrashing
around again trying to figure out you
know a foothold and I just not fair to
him that's not he's he deserves much
better than that and he made the choice
to get it into that uh marriage that
basketball marriage with Kyrie so he has
to to accept that and that was a very
risky decision he didn't need to make
but he doesn't deserve the way he's been
treated in my opinion and he's going to
end up with what 35 000 points maybe
when it's all said and done
I'm guessing
and he could have just stayed in
Oklahoma City and probably been in a
foot race with LeBron for that record he
he's chosen to give up the opportunity
to score although the injuries probably
would have held him back what's LeBron
going to end up with
40 I mean five thousand
well he's he's easily going over 40. uh
he wants to play with his son and I'm
telling you Dan
brawny is good like I'm not saying he's
a headed for being an All-Star
but his development the last year has
been terrific but how do they facilitate
this Brian that everybody knows LeBron
wants to play with brawny so our team's
going to draft brawny to keep him from
LeBron or maybe LeBron wants to join
another team
well that's actually fascinating I
actually think it's gotten more
complicated because if you if we'd had
this discussion last summer I'd have
told you well he's not going to get
drafted yeah and so they'll just sign
them they'll just you know just sign him
as a free agent it won't be a problem
and that maybe even LeBron pulling him
about college after a year might not
even be fair to him but I'm telling you
I don't want to give away like our our
talent evaluators who who do our mock
draft specifically Jonathan cavoni I
trust him implicitly this guy's been
doing it for 20 years he is he has told
me where he thinks brownie is going to
go in the 2024 draft
and I don't
it's not a guaranteed LeBron he's gonna
be able to get him so I actually think
his Improvement has maybe made it more
difficult wait you see a first round
grade
I'm not going to say I'm not gonna you
know I know gavonia is going to come out
with it soon but I'm just saying that
like it's it's not gonna from what I
understand and from what I from what I
am told by people who try you know I
don't trust my own eyes I'm not a
basketball Talent evaluator I would say
watching him from age 15 to age 18 his
physical development has been
breathtaking of course that's what every
teenager
um but I will say this this was not this
is not going to be a nepotism situation
I don't believe I think he's going to be
I'm not saying he's going to again I'm
not saying he's gonna be a top three
pick
but I think he he's going to earn his
way into the NBA on his own if he
continues developing on this path always
great to talk to you Brian thank you for
making a smart weekend yeah YouTube
buddy that's Brian windhorst of the
mothership ESPN senior NBA writer